so guys my name is China welcome back to
remaking my first game in C plus plus
very exciting Series so last time we
ended with a bit of a cliffhanger we had
this uh beautiful situation of random
pixels however they were blurry and they
were blurry because we were using linear
sampling when we actually drew them onto
the screen in some form or another I
think we spent like a good five minutes
maybe even a good one minute trying to
debug this and I decided I'd leave it
for today so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna dive in take a look at how I
approach an issue like this We're not
gonna just like cut to the solution and
that's it I'm gonna hopefully try and
show the journey you know because life's
about the journey it's not about the
destination so from what we concluded
kind of last time
um if we go to so we're using Walnut
obviously Walnut uses I'm gooey that's
how we draw this stuff Walnut also uses
Vulcan to do the actual kind of image
drawing so there's a few kind of moving
Parts here what we know though is we
make a walnut image obviously and we
draw it here using being I'm GUI image
and we take the descriptor set from the
image now there's a lot of there's
probably going to be a lot of Vulcan
terminology here I'm going to try my
best to explain this this series by the
way I didn't really kind of mention the
target audience for this I mean not that
I even get to really control the target
audience but in my mind the target
audience is like beginner to
intermediate for this series right I
mean we're remaking my first game so
there's clearly nothing too complicated
here so whilst there will be some
Advanced things here and as I mentioned
at the very end of this series we're
probably going to vulcanize this whole
thing and that could be Advanced if you
have never kind of done Graphics
programming or Vulcan before in general
I'm going to try and kind of take it
slow and explain things and if you guys
have questions please feel free to leave
a comment and I'll try and like actually
address the comments every episode
um so we make a walnut image this is the
Constructor we're using so we're taking
data we allocate memory for it which
will actually allocate memory on the GPU
for it but the way that like GPU
rendering works is when you have an
image to render you don't just like
render it by like reading the pixels and
then just like copying them into a
buffer the reason why you don't do this
or why well you definitely can do this
just to be clear but the reason why
that's usually not how texturing works
is because if you picture like a 3D
scene this is my little drawing of a 3D
scene maybe I'll do it down here so it
doesn't conflict with the FaceCam so if
we have this like 3D scene here and we
have like I don't know a cube right that
we've decided is going to be like
somewhat textured with something
Pretend This is like a first person
camera and we're moving around this
scene and we're like you know looking at
it from different angles where we're
moving closer towards it we're moving
further away from it you can kind of
start to piece together the fact that
like these pixels that we read from just
a 2d flat image texture the way they
kind of get you know copied onto our 2D
display eventually like the window on
our computer that is actually rendering
these 3D Graphics you know at the end of
the day that's obviously 2D so the way
that kind of projection happens is kind
of all over the place meaning that like
you know if you look at it from like an
oblique angle or whatever you might see
like something like that right I'm
looking at it like kind of side on if
you look at it if you go like really
close to it so that it fills the screen
it might be like this big if you're very
far away might be this big there are all
these ways that this can actually appear
on your screen in the end result and so
because of that it's not as
straightforward as just copying like the
pixels from the texture onto the screen
because there are so many different ways
you could do that depending on if you're
making that text than it actually is if
you're making it smaller like whatever
right and so one of the common ways that
we get to Define that process which
happens by the way automatically on the
GPU we have something called a sampler
and a sampler basically governs how a
texture is sampled and a sampler doesn't
just include like filtering meaning what
happens if you need to magnify the
texture or Minify the texture it also
governs something called wrapping which
is basically what happens if you decide
to use a texture coordinate that is
outside of that zero to one range and
again now we're getting into texture
coordinates I don't really want to go
down that route there's a bunch of other
things that Samplers can control as well
like lots or like which maps are used
and all that stuff we're not going to
get too much into it just focus for now
on the fact that a sampler we use that
or we can use that to kind of determine
what happens if we decide to render the
texture larger than the source kind of
material or smaller than the source
material and that's actually what is
happening at the moment we see that
we're actually trying to draw this image
at a scale and this image scale is three
so are actually scaling up the image by
three the actual texture that we draw
that kind of random all of those random
pixels they're this big but when we
actually render them on the screen
they're this big so clearly we need to
kind of scale this up to fill this area
and so if every pixel is suddenly
becoming you know three in each
Dimension right so this is like the
worst diagram ever but now it's nine
right every pixel has literally become
nine you know what happens to all these
other pixels here's my original pixel
pixel beautiful it's this color right
but what do I do with all of these guys
how do I kind of expand this pixel to
fill up the area of nine pixels well one
of the ways I could do that is I could
take this kind of green pixel and be
like well you know these kind of belong
to this pixel like this is like the
nearest kind of source pixel so why
don't I go ahead and just make them all
green that's pretty straightforward and
what you've basically done is you've
kind of enlarged the pixels here you've
just made the pixels really big the one
pixel now takes up an area of nine
pixels however you could also look at
this kind of in a context you know that
next to it you have another pixel
obviously we have an image made up of
many pixels and this pixel is red
so why don't we in an effort to try and
make this kind of magnification smoother
what we could do is we could kind of
decide to blend these two together so
for these pixels that are kind of nearby
let's I don't know make them kind of
like orangey or like I guess yellow
would be more correct right so we're
kind of we can kind of make these a
little bit more yellow we're kind of
blending these together and so what that
does is it obviously doesn't create a
very sharp result because now you're
creating brand new colors that are never
before seen but it is kind of like it
makes sense to do that if you have like
a literal image or a photograph and you
want to upscale it it makes sense to
kind of try and blend things together
but if you're going for a really sharp
pixelated look you obviously want the
other strategy which is basically saying
that you know what let's just keep these
pixels intact but just make them bigger
and this is something called nearest
filtering
which we briefly discussed last episode
or Point filtering so typically DirectX
calls it Point filtering and then Vulcan
and opengl we call it nearest filtering
same thing it just means that we look to
like the nearest pixel and by the way
these are even like these terms were
even found in like Photoshop when you
scale stuff up and down like using
transform control T so it's not it's not
just exclusive to Graphics apis but we
are kind of talking about them now so
hence why I'm saying this whereas the
other method of kind of you know the
yellow method of kind of blending
everything together that's called linear
filtering and there's kind of different
ways to do linear filtering there's
bilinear there's trilinear there's
there's a bunch of different equations
that can can actually play a role here
but typically talking about Samplers we
can set them to be linear which is this
or we can set them to be nearest which
is like you know just making the whole
pixel that color the best way I always
describe nearest filtering is like
Minecraft textures they obviously remain
very very sharp the pixels just look big
it looks pixelated it looks big but it's
very very sharp there's no blurring
going on there even though the actual
Source textures if I remember correctly
are 16 by 6 16 pixels so they're tiny
but they get Scaled up onto like a block
in Minecraft and they look very sharp
that's because they're being scaled up
they're being magnified using nearest or
Point filtering okay so that's a bunch
of the terminology out of the way so
what's going on here well if we zoom in
we can see that these pixels are nowhere
near sharp actually if I've if I've
zoomed into this level you can actually
start to see each individual pixel and
you can see that each individual pixel
here is a completely different color no
two pixels are the same color right
which is obviously very wrong because
when we actually Drew this in the first
place we obviously set every pixel to be
one color right a single color we do
that over here when we set each pixel to
be a random uint however we've scaled it
up by three so we would expect to see
like three by three pixels being the
same color but we don't and that's
because that linear filtering is
actually happening now that would be
normally easy to fix like we'd go into
our image and we look at what is
actually what sampler we've actually
created it here because that's you know
presumably the sample that's being used
for this actual image and if we take a
look at
um the sample I'll just search for
sample it's got to be somewhere in this
file okay so here it is VK sample
creating for this how we create a
sampler in Vulcan and you can see the
magnification minification filter is set
to nearest now the mipmap mode is set to
linear I'm probably not going to talk
too much about MIP Maps today but
basically that just means that it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the way we sample the texture itself
it's how we kind of blend between MIP
Maps so if we're kind of somewhere in
between like MIP zero and one maybe like
MIP 0.5 because that is totally valid
you can kind of be between bitmaps do we
snap to the nearest mipmap which is what
nearest would be or do we kind of try
and blend between them which is what
linear is so that's fine but we're not
really dealing with maps here at all so
even though the word linear does appear
here these two are actually what apply
to a specific MIP being sampled so they
are in fact set to nearest here's a
sample we create the sampler goes into
the descriptor set and that is the
descriptor set that we actually use here
and a descriptor set by the way is kind
of like it's like a binding to a
resource in Vulcan we at the end of the
day we're going to be using a Shader and
we have like a GPU pipeline that's going
to read this resource and a descriptor
set kind of just or or a descriptor I
should say kind of specifies which kind
of slot in our pipeline binds to which
specific resource such as a buffer or an
image so in this case it's an image
you're basically specifying if my Shader
draws an image which specific image is
going to be for that draw call and
that's kind of what the descriptor sets
up so that descriptor is seen being used
here into imgui image and it kind of
gets passed as texture ID which if we
look at that it's just a void pointer so
it's a 64-bit value and similarly a
descriptor set is also just a
non-dispatchable handle which is just
like a Vulcan handle which also is
um well it's a it's a pointer I think
there's a specific it's really just a
pointer so it's going to be like a
64-bit integer basically so that totally
can audible so all of that kind of makes
sense but why isn't it working so the
kind of problem that we come to almost
immediately here is it's simply not
using our sampler because our sampler
has been set to be nearest not linear
and it looks like we are specifying our
sampler
and in fact if you go into
um so inside Walnut we have this I'm
gooey build file which is which kind of
does a Unity build of two CPP files one
of them is the Vulcan one of them is the
glfw one so these are specific kind of
backhands as you can see for IM GUI if
you look at the actual imgui project
inside uh kind of walnuts dependencies
you'll see there's nothing backhand
specific here it just builds I'm GUI and
then the client application in this case
Walnut you can see this this file is uh
inside you know the Walmart project that
then specifies which backend you want to
use that just makes a little bit more
flexible so that you can kind of choose
to build like different backends
different Graphics apis based on what
you use and this IM GUI isn't like
restricted to build all of them or some
of them and we don't need to change
configurations or anything like that so
basically uh in this case you can see
um this Vulcan CVP file contains all the
Vulcan specific code so this has got to
contain obviously all the Samplers and
then if we go to something called like
rendered draw data which I'm pretty
pretty familiar with I'm gooey so I just
know it's there this is actually what
goes through that kind of all of those
draw kind of lists the draw data I don't
know how deep I should get into how I'm
going works but basically what I'm going
does is it collects this huge list of
like data that needs to be drawn so
basically whenever we execute any kind
of like I'm going to begin which creates
like a new window I'm GUI image which
adds stuff to it like whatever I'm going
stuff we kind of uh you know Paul over
here that actually does stuff that draws
stuff that will just be added into like
this list called a draw list and then
later eventually like at the end of the
frame when all of that has like
concluded and it's time to actually draw
it it will go through that list and
actually execute the draw calls and the
draw commands this is important because
it lets us kind of batch things together
it means that we don't need like a draw
call for everything if we drew it
immediately that would not be anywhere
near as good and that would be quite
limiting actually so we can kind of go
through these draw lists at the end of
the day and actually draw the stuff we
need to draw
um now as part of drawing it we bind
descriptor sets which is US kind of
binding a set of descriptors which
represent resources that we're actually
using in that draw and then we execute
the actual draw call so over here when
it does this you can see what it does
literally for this kind of font or user
texture which is what we're doing at the
moment we're drawing our own texture
here it's supposed to take the
descriptor set which is from the command
the texture ID so if you remember let me
just keep this kind of open and then if
we go to imgui image user texture ID add
image and you can see that kind of
basically will go push texture ID that
will go into that kind of texture ID
slot that is inside like the command
that we're actually like I guess trying
to execute here so if we go back here
that's what that's supposed to be the
commands texture ID is supposed to be
this texture ID that's where we kind of
set it from and then that descriptor set
here now if the size doesn't match for
whatever reason so if the size of IM tax
ID is less than 64 bits which it does
not apply to us but that means we don't
like where I'm tax Friday somehow is in
64-bit so whatever we don't really care
about this Branch at all this is what
happens so this descriptor set gets
bound and what does that descriptor set
it's the set that contains our texture
so clearly it's supposed to be getting
bound here like as far as we can tell
from the code that's actually executing
our sampler which is set to the nearest
filtering is in fact bound however we
see a different result so what do we do
at this point in time now there is from
my from my personal experience there are
lots of other things that could be kind
of the culprit here but I'm going to
pretend I don't really know that to show
you how I would start kind of debugging
something like this and one of the ways
one of the best tools you can use is
basically a graphics debugger such as
renderdoc now what render dock is is
it's a tool that you can use to
basically see what your GPU is kind of
doing or specifically what Graphics API
commands you have decided to execute as
well as inspect certain memory or
textures that you have right and they
also let you kind of look at every draw
call individually and see like what's
actually going on there it's immensely
helpful because instead of looking
through your own kind of code you can
you can see exactly what is actually
happening as well as any parameters that
are like the state that's currently set
now there are two tools that I use
regularly for this when I'm like working
on Hazel and I need like a serious kind
of Graphics debugger for a lot of the
advanced features we use render Dock and
Nvidia and site I basically always run
Nvidia gpus so that's why I use nsight a
lot we do have AMD gpus as well in the
office of course because we support them
as well for hazel however on my
development machine I always basically
have Nvidia and just to kind of show you
inside I guess this latest version and
slight looks very similar you can kind
of go quick launch and then set up like
you know application executable working
directory same kind of options as this
now lots of people always recommend
renderdoc because it's a little bit more
kind of Open Source it's not obviously
specific to like Nvidia like this but I
will just flat out say that Insight is
definitely better this isn't really
meant to be a deep dive on Graphics
debuggers however ansite is much more
detailed especially if you have like a
at least 20 series Nvidia GPU because
then you get some um some much more kind
of in-depth measurements and data like
for example GPU Trace profile is really
good but and it supports DirectX 12 and
Vulcan so that can be somewhat limiting
if you're using something like opengl or
DirectX 11 but anyway the point is I
frequently alternate between the two of
these just because render Dock's a lot
more lightweight in my opinion like it's
less clunky it's much more kind of
straightforward and easier to see what
you're doing but Insight provides much
stronger tools I guess it gives you much
more detail and it basically Works 99 of
the time like there have been many times
where I've opened up renderdoc and I've
inspected my buffers and it's just
incorrect like the data is just wrong
it's just getting it wrong whereas in
inside the data shows up correctly so
that's why I kind of oscillate between
the two I'll usually try renderdoc first
and if it doesn't give me what I need or
I know I need something more in depth
then I'll go to ansite but just know
that there are two options like again
inside obviously only supports Nvidia
gpus however there are multiple options
like every manufacturable like AMD
obviously has their own tools as well
that you can use but renderdoc is just
kind of like a popular thing in between
okay so how do we set this up well
there's this launch application tab it
takes in an executable path working
directory command line arguments and
that just lets us kind of launch your
application so we know that we built
this into a particular directory if we
go into like maybe it'll even be here in
debug
yeah so here's the exe you can see
that's the first thing it loads so I can
just kind of copy the path from here or
you can obviously just go to like the
output directory so like over here
this is where it built the exe2 so I'm
going to copy that path paste it into
here add the genesis.exe at the end now
it needs a working directory now the
working directory in our case is not the
same as the executable directory which
is what it's assuming so we need to kind
of go back to what our working directory
is and it's going to basically be this
uh Genesis directory that has our vcx
project because when we run it through
Visual Studio and this probably doesn't
matter to be honest at this point in
time I don't think we have any resources
to load that are relative to the working
directory but if you go to your um like
property Pages here and you go to
debugging you can see this is just
I decided to turn my scaling up to 150
just so it would be easier to see like
on a small display but of course the
windows still hasn't like figured out
display scaling um you can see the
working directory is Project directory
so therefore when you run it through the
debugger in Visual Studio this is the
working directory so sometimes when you
kind of have files relative to your
working directory which is the project
directory which is this guy over here
then uh you need to also make sure that
you kind of launch that yeah like for
example I guess I'm GUI is really the
only thing I'm going I file which is
like the layout file for our imgui thing
it's really the only file we actually
load here but we'll paste in that
directory no command line arguments
we'll just hit launch and then it's
going to launch this you see we have
like a little uh capturing Vulcan we
have like some text over here from
renderdoc if we just hit F12 now as it
says to capture we get a capture saved
and if we switch back here we have that
capture here now we can either close it
or keep it running and if we close it
it'll automatically load that capture
and now we have
the captcha so what this is is kind of
that entire frame everything that went
into that frame has now been captured
and if we go up here to this timeline
you can see if we kind of Click over
here to expand these little things we
have the all of these different kind of
events and the events show up in the
event browser over here
um and you can see every single event
kind of happens here so if we wanted to
see like every drawer event we could
just type in like the word draw and you
can see if I type in draw here we have
like the three draw calls that happen
for this Frame we can see them over here
and we can see how many indices uh
happen in that drawer as well so pretty
uh useful stuff again much more useful
usually if you're developing like
complex 3D engines and you need to kind
of debug various things that may have
happened but it can be useful for things
like this as well so you can see this is
us so what is this event
um if we kind of clear this filter we
can it should show us this is the VK
command copy buffer to image so this is
us actually setting the data you can see
over here here inside
genesisapp.cpp we every frame do image
set data and then what does that do that
does uh at the end here it does or over
here it records into a command buffer VK
command copy buffer to image so that's
what's happening over here VK command
copy copy buffer to image so these are
the actual pixels and you can see how
nice and big and sharp they are these
are the actual pixels that get copied
into that buffer so they're obviously
correct because no sampler is used here
this is just us copying data from our
CPU to our GPU basically and this is
what it looks like uh that's the data
right
so that's great
um then we submit that queue sure
whatever but then inside is color pass
number one so this is just like you can
see over here in the timeline it says
this is just like a copy clear pass
because we're just copying stuff but
then this is actually a color pass this
is actually an actual render pass this
is where I'm GUI draws everything so
this seems to be like our clear color
and then over here we do command draw
indexed and it doesn't look like we're
really drawing much this might actually
just be the background for I'm GUI
because it's not quite black it's like
.05 so it's like a gray here you can see
the color here by the way if you just
right click uh it will actually sample
pixels and the pixels value will show up
here which can be very useful as well so
you can see that
um value is 0.05 by the way I made a
video about Bloom like a really long
time ago a year and a half ago maybe uh
I use renderdog there quite a lot to
show how unity's Bloom works so I'll
have that video linked up there check it
out if you're interested in kind of how
render Lock Works a bit more in a bit
more of a real context I guess is what
I'm trying to say
um because this is going to be like a
light usage of it uh so there's like the
the top bar being drawn you can see if
we can scrub through here and this is
our texture being drawn and if you look
at it yep that is in fact incorrect
that's like kind of linearly sampled
version and then we have this kind of
inputs over here I might just try and
lower it a bit so you can see
um if we double click on this you can
see the input
this is the source data and the output
is this so clearly the sample is
happening at this exact uh draw call
which is right over here and if we go
into like resource inspector is it
resource inspector pipeline State that's
what I meant pipeline State um you can
see that over here inside like the
fragment Shader which is where that's
being drawn we have an image and sampler
and if we take a look at the sampler
there's a few interesting things here
first of all you'll see the words
immutable sampler more on that later but
if we actually click on this sampler it
takes us to the resource inspector
because a sampler is a resource just
like a texture it's treated as a
resource and then we can actually see
the resource initialization parameters
which is pretty cool so we can see that
how was this sampler created it was
created with VK create sampler you can
already see that it says linear but we
can actually expand this and then you
can see that if we expand create info as
well uh let me just scroll down a bit
I'll make this bigger
you can see that um we actually can see
like literally how this resource was
created in all of its parameters which
is super useful so there's our problem
um we obviously when we created the
sample for the image what did it say
nearest this does not say nearest it
says linear right everything else looks
fine I don't really care about anything
else but this is clearly wrong so this
is clearly a different sampler which
again can be difficult to track down I
guess how exactly that happened because
as far as we're aware when we looked at
the code it was using our sampler we saw
that but the trick is in the fact that
this says immutable sampler what you can
actually do in Vulcan is when you set up
a descriptor set and it has a
discrepancy layout you can actually say
that you know what screw the sample is
provided in the descriptor like just
don't worry about it I'm going to
provide my own immutable sampler meaning
my own kind of read-only not
unchangeable sampler that's what you're
going to use it's almost like an
override and so that has clearly
happened when the pipeline has been
create it now we could dig through I'm
GUI and we could uh try and find where
that descriptive set layout happens
which is probably going to be in some
kind of like pipeline creation code
right however I want to also draw your
attention to this this is the last video
and a lot of you probably think that I
don't read my comments but I do and
whilst doing so I noticed that this guy
Sean Nolan had pointed out that he had
the exact same problem with imq images
it's because I'm going to be ignores the
samples you provide upgrading to the
latest I'm GUI solves it so this is
usually like the best scenario right if
we know that we can just upgrade to a
new version we don't have to go and dig
through the I'm GUI code why is that so
bad because it means that when
eventually changes do happen and we do
want to update we might have merge
conflicts because we've kind of modified
that like third-party library and that
you know if that can be avoided it's a
good thing to avoid it and so what I did
because remember that technically
speaking the I'm GUI that Walnut uses is
actually my kind of fork of I'm GUI
that's on the docking so what I did is I
I updated it like an hour ago right
before recording this video I thought
I'd update it I'd see if that comment
was like correct
what do you know nothing didn't work so
then I was like hmm well either this
Sean character is suspicious and we
shouldn't trust him or maybe it's
because we're on the docking Branch so
what I did was I just went to the kind
of main repository here this is the
master branch and then what you can do
is you can just search right so I
searched for sampler in this repository
and you can search for you can search
through the commits so if you click on
commits you can see that hey check this
out there's a commit which says do not
set description lab binding immutable it
looks exactly like what we're after and
you can see here that in the changelog
it says fixed sampler pass to imgui
Vulcan ad texture not being honored okay
so that sample not being on it and how
was it fixed here is the actual like
diff of code inside this function called
create device objects it's very simple
just remove the font sampler which is
apparently what was being set as the
immutable sampler for this descriptor
set layout binding right so by this line
of code being here by setting an
immutable sampler into that descriptor
set layout we were overriding any
Samplers that were part of the
descriptor set that we were actually
setting in the command buffer so this is
present in the master branch and
actually was only done about a month ago
and I guess it just has not been merged
into the docking branch which is what
we're using but of course it's simple
enough for us to just take this code so
what we'll do is we'll go to that create
device objects function here's our font
sampler being created as you can see
with linear linear that's fine that's
what we want to use for fonts however
for this guy which is just our
descriptive set layout that's used for
like the entire pipeline or like the
main drawing pipeline I guess immutable
sampler you can see is being set to
sampler which is the font sampler so
what we can do is just basically just
not do this and if we don't do this and
we hit our five a look at that we now
have very sharp pixels
so that is basically the solution a
little sneaky immutable sampler was just
set on the actual descriptor set layout
fun indeed now what would have happened
if I'm gooey didn't have the solution
for this well you can see that it says
here that we have an immutable sampler
so really it's just as simple as
searching this file for the word
immutable which happens in a few
different places and really in two
different places and just like removing
it so that we can set our own or
potentially changing this one to be uh
nearest I wouldn't change the font
sampler to be nearest but what I might
have done maybe is I could have
obviously created a new sampler so
another one of these that was set to
nearest call it like nearest sampler or
something and said that as like the the
kind of immutable sampler but I would
prefer not to do that like especially
because in this case when you provide an
image to I'm GUI it makes sense that the
image dictates how it's sampled uh in
this case right and that will be
achieved in our case by just saying that
you know we'll provide iron sampler
which lets us pick nearest on all linear
I've gone ahead and just flat out
changed image to be like always nearest
Which is also wrong you'd usually like
when you create the image maybe you
could specify some parameter that says
this is the kind of filtering I want or
maybe you could even have a separate
abstraction for Samplers that you create
samples can be a bit of a deep topic
just because it makes sense to reuse
Samplers so not for every image to have
its own sampler but to have samples as a
completely separate resource since you
can imagine like a game with thousands
of textures and they will want to be
linearly sampled right or they all want
to be nearest sampled so why would you
provide a thousand Samplers that's just
a waste but yeah that's basically
um all I had planned for today that
didn't really turn out to be that quick
but hopefully it was like comprehensive
and you guys enjoyed it this video is
also not sponsored so if you want to hit
the like button as consolation that'd be
good I just made this video from the
goodness of my heart
um next episode we're probably going to
uh let's actually try and draw some
stuff right so maybe we'll start on like
tile rendering or the the screen class
basically from the Java version because
now that we have this kind of figured
out we can actually start I think
drawing Sprites and that might be a good
thing to do maybe I'll even watch my
game programming series from like 2012
to see uh how that's done but anyway
I'll see you guys in the next episode
bye
[Music]